hola en este vídeo nos piden que
encontremos la suma y simplificamos la
respuesta de este par de fracciones
encuentra la suma y simplifica la
respuesta
esto también es otro proceso que tenemos
que hacer y tengo estas dos fracciones 3
entre 15 más 7 entre 15 date cuenta que
es una suma de fracciones o una suma de
quebrados y cuando nosotros tenemos una
suma de fracciones en lo primero que hay
que fijarnos es en el denominador
recuerda que el denominador es el número
que está abajo de la fracción que es
justo este que tengo aquí este sería mi
denominador de esta fracción y este
también sería mi denominador de esta
otra fracción iv qué creés de lujo el
denominador es el mismo cuando tenemos
una suma de fracciones con el mismo
denominador la suma es un poco más
sencilla que cuando no tenemos el mismo
denominador y hay que encontrar un
denominador en común pero en este caso
tenemos un denominador común que
el 15 y por lo tanto la suma de estos
dos a va a tener como denominador al 15
va a tener como denominador al 15 y
después me tengo que tomar la suma de
estos dos de estos dos que están arriba
es decir 3 + 7 conservamos el mismo
denominador porque es nuestro
denominador común y hacemos la suma de
los números que están aquí arriba de los
dos numeradores y cuentas esto bueno
pues esto es lo mismo que 10 3 + 7 es 10
entre 15 entre 15 ahora si a nosotros
nos pedían solamente encontrar la suma
de estos dos pues sería 10 sobre 15 pero
además nos piden que simplifiquemos la
respuesta y para simplificar la
respuesta necesito encontrar el factor
más grande entre estos dos o dicho de
otra manera un número que divida a estos
dos para que así la fracción se
simplifique extras cuenta el 5 divide
tanto al 10 como al 15 por lo tanto qué
te parece si dividimos esta parte de
arriba entre 5 y también voy a dividir
esta parte de arriba entre sí
y vamos a ver que me sale si divido la
parte de arriba entre 5 me va a quedar
10 entre 5 lo cual es 2 ok y será
dividido esta parte de abajo entre 5 me
va a quedar 15 entre 5 lo cual de estrés
si te das cuenta divide entre el mismo
número tanto arriba como abajo y ahora
si la respuesta simplificada de esta
fracción es dos tercios 3 entre 15 más 7
entre 15 es lo mismo que 10 sobre 15 o
dicho de otra manera es lo mismo que dos
tercios
si nosotros encontramos la respuesta
simplificada ahora qué te parece si lo
visualizamos un poco vamos a ver si
puedo hacer un rectángulo por aquí no
voy a tomar un rectángulo por aquí y lo
voy a dividir en cinco partes primero lo
voy a dividir en una aunque por aquí va
a ser una después por acá voy a tomarme
aunque hay más o menos así después por
acá tengo tres ok y después por acá
tengo 4 y 5 tengo este rectángulo
dividido en cinco partes iguales y ahora
para no hacerlo mucho más largo voy a
copiar este rectángulo lo voy a copiar
por aquí y lo voy a pegar y lo voy a
pegar entonces vamos a copiarlo
aunque ya pegarlo ok ya tengo un
rectángulo parecido a este entonces si
yo lo puedo con este voy a tener un
rectángulo con si aquí tenía 5 pues ya
con este tengo 10 pero lo que necesito
no son 10 partes iguales sino 15 partes
iguales y si yo lo vuelvo a pegar
entonces perfecto me da otro muy
parecido entonces ahora sí lo pego justo
aquí voy a obtener a mis 15 partes
iguales y tú lo puedes pensar como una
barra de chocolate o una barra de dulces
o lo que sea que tenga 15 a pedazos
iguales inclusive también lo podrías
hacer con un círculo primero nos tomamos
3 sobre 15 3 sobre 15 es decir de estas
15 partes
yo me tomé tres de ellas que es esta de
aquí esta de aquí y esta de aquí y
después me tomé la suma de estas tres
primeras partes con otras siete de estas
15 partes con otras siete de aquí o sea
que estas tres le voy a sumar una más
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete para
que en total me den una dos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete ocho nueve diez partes
de estas quince partes que es justo lo
que yo tengo aquí ahora si lo que
quieres ver es que esto es lo mismo que
dos tercios pues qué te parece si
dividimos estas quince partes de aquí en
tres partes iguales si yo lo divido en
tres partes iguales voy a obtener que
esta sería una de las partes esta de
aquí ok
después por acá tengo otra de las partes
estará acá aunque y tengo tres partes
iguales tengo
esta primera parte esta segunda parte y
esta tercera parte y cada una de estas
partes tiene cinco rectángulos y fíjate
que es lo mismo que dos tercios porque
aquí tengo coloreado una primera parte
de estas tres primeras partes una
primera parte de estas tres primeras
partes una segunda parte una segunda
parte de estas tres terceras partes una
segunda parte de estas tres y bueno esta
que sería la tercera de estas tres
partes no está coloreada está
completamente vacía por lo tanto aquí
estoy viendo que es lo mismo 10 sobre 15
que 2 sobre 3 y ya está tenemos la suma
de estos 2